drive one of the best of blowing up  opponents plays  curry gets it in the front court here  he's about a nine second difference  between the shot parking game clock  curry  working against none lets the three go  scores it steph with a huge dagger  curry does it again despite  a five shooting night mark 5 foot 23  from the field the question is how many  shots did he miss  when it matters most the answer no  over kendrick nunn for the knock down  dagger shot  mama there goes that man  and steph curry you see why  part of the reason why he's so much fun  to watch  averaging 30 points a game plays the  game with  so much joy and increased  sportscenter with scott van pelt  folks thanks for watching the nba on  [Music]  espn